for me personally I'm not mature enough
to have a divorce
I'm just not I don't think I would ever
be mature enough I don't because we when
you have to start going in breaking up
assets no I actually think it takes more
maturity to stay together and we define
and redefine that's a maturity I do have
yeah you understand like I know what I
can do and I know what I can't I
actually have more maturity to figure it
out within and work with what I got Jada
Pinkett Smith explaining why divorce is
not an option for her and Will Smith on
our Facebook watch series at read table
talk we don't talk about it we're not
gonna get to the other side we're just
gonna you know things are just gonna
stay in the cracks and fester Jada says
her mom adrian has actually questioned
her marriage to will the couple no
longer calls themselves husband and wife
instead they use the term life partners
she was like well why don't y'all just
divorce one of the ideas for me is that
we built such a beautiful community
we've built such a beautiful family and
our survival we do well together and
then breaking that group and community
up for me
it's just never an option you know I
won't say that it's easy but you know
one of the things that will and I take a
lot of pride in is being able to balance
it by really understanding our family
and one another as artists we love doing
what we love to do and we flow so much
light and power to one another to do it
that's the thing that keeps us connected
partnering is a lot more than romance
yeah it has a lot to do with survival
resources and just having somebody or
somebodies by you that can help you
figure it out it's your back yeah Jada
and Adrian were joined at the table by
Grammy winner Toni Braxton who divorced
Keri Lewis in 2013 I hate it being
divorced I hated everything about it I
hated having to surrender to the loss
that surrendering doesn't always mean
defeat it was a successful marriage
in less than 12 years and that's what it
was supposed to be that's right it
doesn't have to be infinity Tony said
she could relate to Jada's idea of
keeping the community you build strong
she still celebrates holidays with her
ex he's an extension of my family not
just because he's my kids dead but
because he was a part of my life but it
was not an easy divorce Tony says her
marriage fell apart due to money issues
she got sick with lupus and couldn't
work if I'm gonna be completely honest
it was money was just the decoration on
the tree right the tree itself was I
felt because I was sick he left so it
gave me maybe insecure right ironically
she says she had to pay her ex alimony
after their split that's what I was so
angry about like I pick it out the bed
so I can pay this debt
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
today Tony is no longer brokenhearted
she's engaged to rapper Birdman how did
you know that Birdman was the one well
you know he and I've been friends for a
really long time for like 17 years and
it just grew from friendship to more
than that so you got to keep your
friends close you never know what could
happen you know the red tape I love the
red table but the red table makes you
emotional talk about it yeah soothing at
the end
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]